哈囉 我是小災雲 今天想分享我
但畫眼文和黑眼圈的方法
這是我自己時間下來發現
效果真的非常好的一套眼部保養方法
他不只會讓我們的眼中
幾乎得到感受
還會讓我們的眼睛都變得更有神意形
因為這幾年我發現
經常有朋友誇我說我的眼睛亮亮的
因為我是帶了美同
但其實我從來不帶眼睛眼睛
而且這麼多年來我的勢力
是越來越好
我是可以看到那個勢力表上了
到處第二排的
所以今天把我眼部
把要的秘密都分享給你們
我發現想要眼部裝在好
一定要經常的用眼油去按摩
放鬆眼中
這樣可以加速眼中的循環去服種
也會讓我們的眼睛看起來更有神
我結合了我在美容院做的
一千塊錢以次的眼部是霸和眼部
波經總結了一套非常簡單的眼部按摩操
我是只要不滿我幾乎每天晚上
都會做這個眼部按摩操
做完的當下就會感覺眼睛舒服的
很多很多
那在眼油方面的我喜歡用這款來搭配
其實我用過很多款眼油
這一款它不是最貴的
而且它非常的平價
但是確實我用下來覺得最舒服的一款
我是那種眼招幾乎側邊的感用
很多小細文
而且黑眼圈很重的人
它就可以幫我解決我的這些眼招問題
特別是在黑眼圈方面
因為它裡面有一個成分
叫永久花金油
這個成分它就是黑眼圈的課心
然後裡面還有很多黑老景質的油
重點是它的這個某感很舒服
不有你
是我們皮膚能夠吃的進去的油
它不會浮在表面上感覺
吸收不進去
所以我用它來搭配我的這個眼部按摩操
效果特別好
小乾耳那黑眼圈都還剪了很多
用完眼油之後呢
我還會再搭配一個眼霜
在眼霜方面我今天用到的一款
非常精細的眼霜
就是這個高麻微眼霜
這是我用過很多搭配眼霜
但是大部分的眼霜
對我來說我就感覺只有保持
對我的眼文
能沒有什麼效果
但是這款眼霜
我用完它的聽二天
早上起來照鏡子就很精細
就我發現我的眼霜
幾乎變得很飽滿
就是飽滿到那種
小小的細文
都被撐開的感覺
然後眼霜也沒有之前的乾別了
去搜它的成分
我發現它裡面都是一些
非常安慰的植物
黑老成分
可以幫助我們眼窩
變得更碰
然後眼霜會變得更精致
裏面眼霜了
一些少量的衣純
我非常喜歡有衣純的眼霜
就是黑老小的非常好
但是它們家的衣純
做得非常溫和
我用它都沒有去接靈耐受
至低呢
也是這種
比較潤
但是呢
非常好吸收
一點都不厚重
所以如果有眼部
黑老需求的寶寶
你已經用過很多大牌的眼霜
都感覺效果一般
那你就要試一試
這個高麻油眼霜
我覺得它的性價比又高
但是黑老的效果
有真的很好
那我來總結一下
就是如果想要
淡化眼睛
很遠確認我們的眼部
狀態變得更好
你一定要清長的用眼
有做眼部按摩
加速我們眼睛的循環
在配合一款黑老效果
非常好的眼霜
幫助就OK啦
當然大家最好還是不要老眼
早點睡覺